money is the equivalent of energy so you
can buy energy with your cash and the
significance about that is if you're
Frugal and take care of your money and
keep a balance then you always have this
energy in your bank account energy in
which you can live however obviously if
you waste this energy then you actually
interfere with your own Survival so you
don't really want to go out and just
throw away your money and so basically I
really want to show you that this is an
important insight into the nature of our
own health and our biology in the world
recreate in this regard that our
biological system the cells rely on
energy without energy there's no life so
fundamentally you have an energy budget
that gives you life and in fact in the
body energy is in coins called ATP
molecules that represent units of energy
so in fact biologists refer to ATP as
the coin of the realm the significance
of ATP is this is that ATP molecules are
like units of gasoline like gallon of
gas that are used to fuel our biological
processes so to stay alive we have to
have all this ATP so there's an ATP
account in your body right now need
motivation what's your top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because you you
probably the most the most ambitious
person in your circle but you know
you're capable of more and you get that
Push by surrounding yourself with the
best so today let's learn from one of
the best Bruce Lipton and my take on his
top 50 rules for Success enjoy
but the question is how do you use this
ATP and now here's an important fact
that 25 of the total energy in your
whole body is used to operate your brain
so all of a sudden you start to
recognize that the brain uses energy at
the rate of muscles of a marathon runner
so a brain and muscle activity are
pretty much the same and so why is this
important because as you're using your
brain as you're using your thinking you
are actually using energy now why is
this relevant the answer is very simply
this because the way we've been using
our thoughts are not necessarily
productive a matter of fact sometimes
our investments of our thoughts are
actually counterproductive because our
thoughts create a reality that we then
have to overcome so basically it says
that we must start to become aware of
our thoughts and why is this important
because thoughts represent units of
energy every time you have a thought you
use energy why this becomes relevant is
if I give you a checkbook for your bank
account you don't go down the street and
just write checks to people like oh hey
you're a nice looking guy here's 10
bucks for you and oh here little girl go
out and buy yourself a little car here's
a thousand dollars for you and you don't
give away your money why because giving
away your money is giving away your life
so basically you become very frugal when
you have a checkbook in your hand now
what I'm trying to tell you is this you
have an energy budget in your body the
energy is what keeps you alive when you
start using energy and writing checks
where you get no return from your energy
then it's exactly the same as writing
checks out of your bank checkbook and
giving away your cash so why this
becomes important is the biology of
belief reveals how our thoughts create
our reality and if you start investing
in thoughts that are counterproductive
thoughts like fear or what am I going to
do and how am I going to escape this
problem or how's this going to go wrong
and all these other kinds of thoughts
that are negative kinds of thoughts then
realize this you are actually not just
using your energy for having these slots
but these thoughts are also what come
into your reality what you focus on with
your thoughts your brain will manifest
as reality in 1925
physicists said that our vision of a
universe split into an invisible energy
realm and a material Physical Realm was
a total illusion that everything is
energy the whole thing there is no
matter in this world and to summarize
what the meaning was of famous
physicists in 1930 by the name of Sir
James jeans said we have been led to
believe that the universe is a great
machine when in fact it is more a great
thought
and the reality about that was quantum
physicists have established since 1925
that Consciousness is the primary
mechanism of creativity of the world
that we experience in fact a more recent
article in the journal Nature which is
like a a scientific mainstream Journal
was an article by a Quantum physicist at
Johns Hopkins University by the name of
Richard con Henry and his article was
entitled the mental universe I I know
the last two lines in the article
because they were like so powerful and
here's what the conclusion of the
article was
the universe is immaterial it's mental
and spiritual live and enjoy and this is
so exciting because science is coming
out saying it mental and spiritual is
like oh my God but that's the quantum
physics part and the reality about it
why is that so important as uh Assad
Vijaya just mentioned it's our thoughts
that are manifesting this world now you
can say that's a spiritual thing and now
I say not only is it spiritual now it is
fundamental basic science of the
universe and it says then the thoughts
are creative well if the thoughts are
created then who is having the thought
and you start to realize I'm having a
thought well then the truth is simple as
Richard con Henry said you are creating
this world with your mental activity and
your spirituality combined and then all
of a sudden it says well then if I'm
creating the world then my original
belief that when things didn't go right
I was a victim the universe wasn't
supporting me you know it's like oh I
try so hard and the universe is not
giving me things it turns 180 degrees
around and it basically says this
we are creating this world
and then I say your mind is creating
this world I was looking for
relationships I kept failing at him okay
I end up in the Caribbean teaching at a
medical school
the universe throws this into my lap the
perfect pickup line in the whole world
is sort of like hey if you're not doing
anything you want to come and stay in my
villa in the Caribbean and hang out I
have a villa on the beach and I got my
own place and uh blah blah blah and I
still wasn't able to find anybody but I
kept looking because I said I need a
relationship I need a relationship so I
meet this woman who comes off of some
yacht and she's you know I've got a
future that's like she's doing what she
wants and I thought well if you're not
doing anything why don't you uh you want
to come and stay with me and my Villa on
this beautiful Island
he looked at me and she looked at me and
then she said I can't be with you and I
sort of like stop for a moment and she
looked at me and she says you're too
needy
it hit me I said oh my God what am I
looking for a relationship why because
you're not happy so if you're looking
for a relationship because you're not
happy then you're depending on that
relationship to make you happy so that's
not a nice relationship it's
codependency if I give you this place to
stay you will make me happy that's a
trade you know it's like yes and after
she said that I was stunned for a moment
I can't be with you you're too needy she
said and I was and then all of a sudden
I said Thank you thank you very much it
was sort of a slap in the face right the
blessing in disguise right it totally
was it was like wake up and I walked
away from that and I looked at my life
and said you got this most amazing job
you teach a couple days a week you live
in the Caribbean you've got a villa you
got money in your pocket because you get
paid and there's nothing to buy in the
Caribbean anyways I got I say you're
healthy you got money you got a great
place to live you have the most
wonderful job I go you can't be happy
with that that's what I said to myself
I said how can I you know I'm looking
for this person to make me happy I said
oh no first I make me happy yeah and
then why make me happy
that changed and it did what happened is
I stopped bitching and started to enjoy
look don't you love where you live yeah
I love where I live do you love Lucia oh
I love the sea you like it oh I love my
job and all of a sudden I started
focusing on hey these are things I love
and guess what
I didn't need anybody
that's when you created abundance and
that's when people became attracted to
you right 100 because once I didn't need
them I wasn't like yeah come here I was
like ass I don't care it's fascinating
how it works and they showed up they
showed up because I did not need that
was the word because need puts pressure
on that other person that they have to
provide and then they didn't have to
provide it was like hey let me hang out
with you I don't have to provide
anything I could just be me I go yeah
you be you I'd be me we have a great
time
and that was the beginning of
reprogramming a need for a relationship
until I was happy with myself and until
that happened once I was happy with
myself and I didn't need a relationship
you should have seen how many
opportunities showed up that were never
there in my life before because the need
part pushed them away I was cloning stem
cells back in 1967. 40 years ago and the
significant against was while I was
doing this research I was also teaching
medical students so I was teaching
medical students the foundation of how
cells work the conventional story out of
the textbook genes control life what we
call the genetic determinism the belief
that genes control your traits Behavior
your physical characteristics Etc and
what my research revealed when I was
studying the stem cells was this very
profound I put one stem cell in a Petri
dish all by itself and it would divide
every 10 to 12 hours so it'd be 2 4 8 16
cells 32 cells after about two weeks I
have thousands of cells in the petri
dish but what was unique they were all
genetically identical but then I did the
experiment the experiment was to take
some cells out of the dish and put them
into a separate dish with a different
environment okay and so the environment
is a culture medium but the culture
medium to cells is like the world that
we live in it's got the air the water
the food all the things in it so I take
the cells out of my stem cell dish put
them in a separate dish with a different
environment and the cells form muscle
but then I went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells in it
took some cells out put them in a
different environment and they form bone
and then I went back to the same dish
with genetically identical cells and put
them in a third petri dish with a
different environment and they form fat
cells and there I was confronted with
this reality all the cells are
genetically identical but they had
different fade fat muscle bone I say
simple question what controls the fate
of cells and the answer is the
environment it was the only thing that
was different because they were all
genetically identical so I started to
really say oh my goodness here I am
teaching genes control life to the
medical students and yet the cells were
revealing to me that hey they all had
the same genes but it was the
environment that I put them in and so
the environment controlled their life
and a very simple experiment that is
very profound for us today is if I took
my dish with plastic petri dish with
cells in it and moved it from a healthy
environment to a less and healthy
environment the cells get sick and if I
were a doctor of cells I you might say
well what kind of drugs would you give
these cells and it turns out no you
don't give the cells any drugs you just
take the dish from the bad environment
put it back into a good environment and
the cells will innately naturally come
back to health again also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I designed a special
free worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there the
science that says there are two minds
that are operating at the same time one
is called the conscious mind and one is
called the subconscious mind I say
What's the difference
the conscious mind is where you are as a
spirit an entity a unique identity you
are in that conscious mind and
perceiving the world I say what about
the subconscious mind it's not a
creative mind the subconscious mind is
habits things that you've learned and
you experienced in your life and they
become habits so uh the subconscious
mind is not thinking creating a
subconscious mind push the button play
the behavior
so here's the point
when we are in our conscious mind we are
connecting our spirituality to the
biology and the physical planet that
we're in and that is a creative mind
that's the one you wake up in the
morning and say oh I wish I had this and
I desire that and these are the things I
want and then you go out and start the
day and then guess what
95 of the day you are not operating from
the conscious mind science is recognize
95 of the day because we are thinking 95
percent of the day our behavior is now
controlled by the subconscious mind
I go okay so what's the difference in
the final conclusion of this is the
conscious mind with your creativity has
your wishes and your desires
the subconscious mind was programmed by
other people your mother your father
your siblings and your community so what
is the difference you wake up with a
wish and a desire of what you want
and then the rest of the day you play
the programs that you got from other
people that don't answer your wishes and
don't support your desires and all you
see is the consequence of it and go oh
my God why is it not working the answer
is because you don't see because
remember the name is subconscious below
conscious so when that behavior is
playing
psychologists will tell us 70 percent or
more of the programs in the subconscious
are disempowering
self-sabotaging and limiting behaviors
so the simple reality is this we have
great wishes and desires and yet our
life is not controlled by that our life
is controlled by the programming and
that programming is the disempowering
program so all you see is the
consequence of the invisible
subconscious which will sabotage all the
desires and wishes you have and then to
conclude that
what if you just didn't default to the
subconscious what if you just stayed in
the conscious mind that's called being
Mindful and why is it relevant because
when you stay conscious keep your mind
present you are the creator of your life
and when people are in mindfulness they
manifest their wishes their desires and
their happiness so for all of us it's
sort of a wake-up call you think you're
running your life with your wishes and
desires it's an illusion you're really
running your life with your programs
acquired from other people well how do
you change the subconscious mind say how
did it learn in the first place
I say what was the first one I say Theta
seven years brain was functioning lower
vibration than Consciousness you have to
slow down the brain to a much slower
vibration then it goes into the
subconscious mind that's why um
hypnotherapists in the old days they had
a watch and they would swing it back and
forth so the watch would swing and they
would tell the person you're getting
sleepy you're getting tired and the
reason they say that is because that
shuts down the conscious vibration and
the next vibration is Theta which is
hypnosis so to get you into hypnosis
first I have to get your conscious brain
to stop
and then in hypnosis State Theta the
vibration Theta then whatever is coming
from the outside is not going into my
conscious mind whatever I see on the
outside is going into my subconscious
program
so if you want to change the
subconscious you have to talk to the
subconscious they go how do you do that
well number one hypnosis and I go oh
what I need to see the hypnotherapist I
go no this is the cool part I say why I
said we have different vibrations the
lowest vibration is Delta is sleep the
next higher vibration is Theta hypnosis
imagination the next higher vibration is
Alpha calm Consciousness and the next
higher vibration is called beta which is
like School room like what we're doing
here Consciousness okay I go so why is
it rub I said when you're asleep you're
at the lowest and when you start to wake
up you go up first to Theta and that's
like in the morning where you're half
awake and half asleep and then I say but
then when you're awake you're an alpha
now you're in Consciousness and then
when you go to work you're in beta which
is like the work in Consciousness but
when you come home it reverses so I come
home from work I'm in beta but I relax
oh the conscious says vibration slows
down the alpha and here's the fact the
moment that the vibrations get a little
lower than Alpha Consciousness is now
shut off for the night you're sleeping
yeah but there's a period of time after
Alpha shuts off before it reaches Delta
the lowest one there's a period of time
of theta I go y's irrelevant I said you
put earphones on
and the moment and you play a program of
what of what you want a self-help
program of have a mega relationship be
healthy and do a job whatever you get
the program self-help program I say you
put it on on a CD player let's say and
you put the earphones on and while
you're still awake just before you go to
sleep you can hear what's going on but
the moment you fall asleep conscious
mind shut off but guess what Theta is on
the work is getting done right right
you're getting a self-hypnosis with the
earphones so whatever the you didn't
hear it you were sleeping the
subconscious mind was hearing it and
when you repeat that that's how you put
a new program in so that's number one
self-hypnosis I had tenure I had tenure
at the University I walked out of the
university and said look I I can't keep
my integrity and at the same time teach
something I know was patently wrong so I
walked out because I saw that teaching
the belief that genes control life was
very very Incorrect and it's very
interesting because I did that in 1970
now that's like 30 40 years ago when we
look at our lives and I tell you that 95
of your life is coming from the
subconscious program
this is not it's new on a scientific
awareness of how this mechanism works
but what's interesting is for 400 years
the knowledge that you could program
somebody and control their lives has
been available it was the Jesuits who
400 years ago said give me a child until
it's seven and I will show you the man
most people didn't understand what they
were saying and what it is is the first
seven years which we now know
biologically and scientifically is the
program period they knew that 400 years
ago and they said if I can get that
program in in the first seven years that
program will determine the life of that
individual I'll show you the man because
they will represent the program
now the really important part is since
every one of us has been programmed the
the big issue is so what were those
programs because if I ask you so what
what program did you get when you were
one year old
I have no idea I wasn't really there and
in fact you were actually being
programmed even before you were born the
last trimester of pregnancy you were
being programmed and I go well this is
really a critical issue because the
first thing I'm telling you is your life
is 95 program uh and most of that is is
really disempowering and of course the
first thing I would think is and what
are those programs so I could deal with
them so I want to make something very
easy for you so you don't have to go and
review your whole life and try to figure
out what the programs are save you a lot
of time
the fact is this you are playing the
program 95 of the day meaning your life
is a printout of your program so you
don't have to go back in time to review
that would just actually irritate the
system more because every time you
review those things that unsettled you
when when you were younger it just
reinforces that same pain that you had
earlier so going back uh and finding out
who did what to who uh is more than just
a waste of time it actually will set you
back as a matter of fact there's an an
old phrase that people have heard and it
says Don't Kill the Messenger over the
message
what that means is this don't go back
and blame all the people that did this
and that and that and that that's
irrelevant who they are is irrelevant
what's relevant is what program did you
walk away with not who did the event but
what you learned so now I said okay I've
been programmed and I have no idea what
the program and I said then look at your
life and here's the simple resolution
everything in your life that you like
and it comes to you is because you have
a program to support that that's
wonderful that means that's great it's
going to come to you because that
program is bringing it to you but in
contrast this is the one that's
important
anything you work hard to accomplish
anything you struggle over to make it
happen anything you put a lot of effort
in I want this I'm going to work like
crazy I'm gonna get this my first
question is why are you working so hard
and the answer is very simple
anything you're struggling to try to
accomplish whether it's health or love
relationships whatever it is
if you're struggling it represents a
simple fact your subconscious
programming doesn't support that
conclusion so the fact is what are my
programs look at your struggle and
wherever you're struggling the struggle
is not because the universe won't
provide for you the struggle is an
internal job the struggle is you're
trying to overcome previous programming
that prevents you to go to that
destination so the wonderful part about
this understanding is you don't have to
to review your life you can look right
now at this one moment just look in your
head and say what are the things that I
keep trying to get and they they seem to
be elusive I can't get them they're
always Out Of Reach I say their their
universe is not holding back
it's your own invisible subconscious
behavior when you're putting in a wish
and a desire put it in as if you already
have it
I am healthy I am a good relationship
person I you know I have a great job
what's that I say it's like I already
have it and yet most people don't have
it so they'll say I want a great job I
want a great relationship I want to be
healthy and I go make a recording of
those words we just said that I want to
be healthy today right now Tuesday we're
going to make a recording I say now come
back in one year and let's push the
button on that recording and we come
back a year later and it says I want to
be healthy I go it's a whole year and
you still want to be healthy still don't
have it right you didn't say I am
healthy all you're emphasizing I have a
desire to be healthy I want to be
healthy I have a desire to be health and
I go
you can have that desire the rest of
your life you're not going to get
healthy you want to be healthy you say I
am healthy but then you look and say
yeah but in reality I'm sick and I go no
no the function of the mind is to take
the program and turn it into reality so
if I am sick but I put a program in I am
healthy the Mind looks you know like
well wait a second the program is I am
healthy but the body is not healthy so
what's the function of the Mind
create Health in the body it doesn't
change the program it changes the body
and so the idea is this every time we
put a program in it has to be as if you
already have it and it's by the fact you
could be dying of cancer I go I am
healthy it sounds kind of weird and I go
don't worry about it just put it on I am
healthy because once it is a program the
function of the mind is to manifest it
as reality
that's the part and so my little caveat
you brought it up I'm emphasizing it and
that was simply this that whatever
you're downloading you have to say it as
if you already have it because if you
put a future tense on it I will I want I
say if you record that that means you
will always will you know want to have
it you know I will do this you won't get
there so I just wanted to bring that in
because if we're making a program then
you must make sure it says as if you
already have it in spite of the fact you
don't yo ho ho and about love from the
dead man's on the la la la la la la la
la
oh wow what a glorious day to be sailing
on the sea
I think I should be checking my bearings
at this point
North by Northwest that's that's right
Hank told me take a left at the island
then follow North by Northwest and until
I go towards the sunset but it should be
here somewhere Long Island should be
somewhere but
it's not here
I think I better check my calculations
again
so I left Port Moresby at 12 and going
at eight knots by 12 35 we should have
been over here take the left of the
island and then we followed the tangent
of the cosine of 381 for eight minutes
to the right and then we should be
approaching toward Kong Island
uh uh
uh oh
I'm lost at sea
what should I do now
I knew I should have trusted my feelings
when Hank gave me directions it just
didn't even feel right and in today's
world we're told don't go by the
feelings if I did I would have probably
been better off at this moment so when
we recognize we have to make a decision
we can do it in two fundamental ways
first do an assessment an analysis of
step by step what does this decision
mean and why should I choose it but when
you get to the end before you absolutely
take that information and make a
decision based on that
ask your heart and the reason why is
this the heart doesn't care about the
individual steps in the decision the
heart only looks at the conclusion
either you get more energy from this
decision a good vibe a feeling that this
is right or the heart will give you a
feeling of bad vibes less energy a
feeling that maybe this isn't the right
answer so the significance is really
profound because the heart just reads
energy and higher energy is more life
less energy is less life so in making a
decision yes it's acceptable to do the
analysis but before you come to that
final decision please check in with your
heart feel the feelings if the feelings
are good that means go toward that
direction but if they feel questioned
about it if you feel weaker about it
doesn't just feel right the heart is
telling you right off that that energy
is not good for you and you should use
some other decision oh wow that's so
wonderful what a wonderful way to make a
decision based on these feelings and
they can help us find the direction that
we need to go in and lead us to a better
life
uh oh
I guess that's not really working for me
at this moment
whoops
oh well
computer and simulation
Scotty how many times have I told you
not to leave me off and see you know I
can't swim
meet me at the bridge you have some
explaining to do I don't care how much
knowledge is in your head if that
knowledge doesn't go into your
subconscious your life will stay exactly
the same as it was you can be the
brightest smartest academic and I say
fine did it change your life and the
answer is no
you have to take the knowledge that you
are walking within your conscious mind
and put that knowledge into your
subconscious programming and when you do
that you are all-powerful in the
creation of your own life and so just
walking around and being able to recite
all these wonderful sayings and things
that you hear from all the wonderful
teachers that we have and you say oh yes
I remember that that's a good quote
that's a nice quote Oh that's a
wonderful saying
it's irrelevant
until that saying becomes part of your
program because now you are living from
the saying and not talking about the
saying and that was the total
transformation of a life that on an
academic level was successful on a
personal level I don't even want to talk
about that uh but it changed everything
why
because instead of having to chase
afterlife
after this understanding things came to
me the light will bring it to you the
only thing that's in your way of the
light is a block in your belief that
other people have put into your
programming you take your knowledge that
you have make it your subconscious
program and you will manifest all of the
wonderful spiritual wisdom that you have
heard throughout your whole life is not
words now it is life and behavior and
that's our destination everything you do
in your life you put out energy for
therefore start to review what you're
doing in your life because if you're
putting your energy into things you
cannot change in this world that is
exactly the same as writing a check and
just throwing away your money to the
outside because you get nothing back
from it so think about this very
interesting reality that you have this
energy checkbook and every time you use
energy you have to say is the use of
this energy going to enhance my life or
is it just wasted energy am I getting
involved in a in a political argument
with people where I'm going to use up
all my energy and will I have changed
the world no
am I going to use up all my energy to
try to convince other people to change
their life or change their way of living
to make them even healthier and they're
not ready to do that I'd be wasting my
energy
so here's an interesting thought
if I gave you an energy checkbook and
asked you to write a check every time
you had to have a thought you would have
to then ask yourself is is this thought
going to enhance my life or is this
thought going to take away from my life
and then when you start to realize that
you start to direct your actions where
you put your energy into things that
enhance your life and give you an
opportunity to survive and to go Beyond
Survival and really into thriving
so the point is this we are facing some
rough times the more thoughts you put
into the negative aspect the more
thoughts you put into the fear uh not
only are you just wasting your energy
but as in the biology belief these
negative thoughts these negative
stresses actually impair your immune
system and bring on disease itself the
thinking is not that much in our control
the brain is operating as I said 95 from
the subconscious
but how did you actually then get
results in a relatively short space of
time well the first thing how does a
subconscious learn and that's a very
critical thing uh the conscious mind can
learn from reading a book so you the
subconscious mind can read a self-help
book and you go wow that sounds really
great and then you find you read the
book but your life is still the same and
this turns out why and the answer is
because the subconscious mind is more of
a habit mind things that you repeat over
and over again so the reality is if you
can stay conscious
be present and when those negative
thoughts come in our head and
psychologists tell us 70 of the time the
thoughts that are going through our head
are negative and redundant so the same
negative thoughts are going through if
you could stop those thoughts if you
could hear them as they come through
like oh that's not going to work oh this
will never happen those kind of thoughts
if you can hear them and stop them
consciously say no uh change the belief
right there just give the more positive
thing as you repeat this more frequently
and you keep repeating it the
subconscious mind begins to learn so as
a habit if you stay conscious and you
have to work at it and here's why people
say well how come only five percent from
conscious mind 95 from subconscious
because a conscious mind can think into
the future and think into the past and
solve problems then think about it
yourself most of the time you're
thinking about something well if you're
thinking you're using the conscious mind
well if you're using a conscious mind
for thinking then who's running the show
and the answer is when you're not paying
attention and you're thinking about what
I'm going to do tomorrow your
subconscious is running so Jesus told
his followers all the Miracles that I
can do you can do them but even better
than I can and you don't believe it and
that was the whole damn thing in a
nutshell if you don't believe it you
can't do it and I said well where's
belief come from mind I say you know
what have you been programmed you can't
do and I said then you'll never be able
to do it
and this is the problem and I and so we
talked about way number one you want to
change it hypnosis because that's the
original way things went in in the first
place and you're you know you that what
you said was true the evenings just say
I feel amazing I feel amazing if you
repeat that the mind will will all of a
sudden change how you feel that's that's
how it does it okay so I say number one
self-hypnosis number two after age seven
you still learn how to do new things
that become habits like you didn't learn
how to drive a car until until later
than seven but once you know how to
drive a car remember the first day you
got in it was like oh my God looking out
the windows checking the mirror watching
the gauges keeping your feet on the
pedals just correctly you know looking
paying all these attentions like and I
say today you've been driving for a
while you don't even think about that
you get in the car you put the key in
and now what are you thinking about well
what am I going to do when I get to the
store you're not even thinking about
driving why it's a habit okay I say well
how did you get that habit because
you're older than seven how'd you get it
I said repetition that's what makes a
habit practice you want to play an
instrument I'll hand you an instrument
yeah you didn't have any practice then
you're not going to be able to play it
and I say oh practice what is that
repetition
that's the second way of the
subconscious learns repeating something
over and over and over again because
that's called habituation making a habit
and I love it the new age today thing is
fake it till you make it I go what the
hell is that I say you're not happy yeah
most of us have trouble being happy and
I say but what if every day all day long
and you can remember you say I am happy
in spite of the fact that what the hell
is going on you just say I am happy I am
happy I am happy I go why what's going
on I say repetition and it'll be a point
where you'll repeat it to the degree
that the subconscious which learns by
repetition will put in I am happy I said
then what's the consequence I said
what's the function of the Mind take
that program and manifest it now that
it's in there I am happy I wake up one
morning guess what I don't have to say
I'm happy it's automatic I'm already
happy all day long why my program said
that 95 is coming from that habituation
you know repetition of the exact thing
you want not Future Vision as if you
have it now we'll put it in a program so
that's first seven years hypnosis after
seven years uh repetition habituation is
how you change it uh a sticky note
people put that stuff on a mirror or
someplace and they go oh yeah those
thinking out and I go that is not
repetition that's a suggestion a
repetition is a practice you have to
repeat things that's you practice an
instrument you practice driving a car
you practice doing these things and then
it became real okay so the first two
things are uh hypnosis second thing is
repetition and thirdly the most you know
is called Energy psychology and I go
what's energy psychology it's called
super learning you know so what the hell
is super learning I go maybe you've seen
somebody read a book by picking up a
book and just moving their finger down
the page just like that just as fast as
that
and guess what the subconscious mind the
super computer that it is has read every
word just by moving your finger down
around is read every word on that page
and a person using the super learning
technique can go into a bookstore open
up a book and five minutes later by
thumbing through each page Turn the Page
Turn the Page Turn the Page they can
read a whole book in five minutes that's
super learning I say if you can engage
that function
you can also use super learning to
create new programs not in days or weeks
but you can create a new program in
minutes it's like I go absolutely and
it's so important why because uh there's
an old phrase that's really critical
it's called necessity is the mother of
invention and I say what's happening
we're facing a mass extinction due to
human behavior that is compromising the
Web of Life humans are creating this
through our Behavior or culture I say
you want to survive this episode this
whole you know Extinction event well
then you have to create something
different you have to change Behavior I
was a scientist and as a scientist we
don't bring spirituality and mind into
the story it's all genes and cells and
molecules and all that and my research
uh on on stem cells uh revealed that
while I was teaching in medical school
that genes control life my research
revealed that it was the environment in
which the cells lived that control the
cells it was outside information coming
into the cells and and I remember how
specifically in a moment of time that I
was working on trying to understand the
mechanics from a molecular point of view
how does an environmental signal control
biology and I was working not on the
genes I was working on the skin of the
cell the membrane and it was it was so
profound I it's hard for me to even
describe it I'm working on the
understanding how does information from
the environment control biology and I
had looked at the membrane for years and
I wrote a new definition of the
mechanism of the membrane
and I wrote this definition and this is
in 1985. it was about 2 A.M and I wrote
down the membrane is a liquid Crystal
semiconductor with Gates and channels
when I wrote that down there was a pause
and I said I I just I read something
exactly like that and right next to my
first computer Macintosh was a book from
a simple book of understanding your
microprocessor and I opened it up and I
said somewhere and I open it right in
the introduction it said a chip
is a crystal semiconductor with Gates
and channels and I thought oh what a
coincidence they have the same
definition
and then in a couple of seconds I
started to say wait a minute
one for one the parts are exactly the
same I said oh oh my God the membrane is
a computer chip
and on the surface of the cellar like
Keys like on a typewriter and and I
started to realize oh my goodness the
environment is typing on the surface of
the cell information that went into the
cell and control the genetics and the
behavior and it was like oh oh this is
real exciting and I'm typing on my own
computer typing this information in and
then I realized I am outside of the
computer typing on the keyboard and the
information is coming up on the computer
then I said oh my God
this keyboard on the surface of your
cells has a number of keys that
represent a PIN number a personal
identification number and no two of you
have the same keys on that each of us
have a different pin number to get into
our own cells it's our personal identity
and these are the keys and I realized oh
my god well we've been focusing on these
what are called receptors as the source
of identity I realize no it's what's
activating what's typing is the identity
and then it hit me and said oh my God my
identity is not in the cell my identity
is a signal coming from the environment
typing in the keyboard and then I said
oh and the first thing that hit me was
I can't die I'm not even in here
and that instant of fear which all of us
have in our deepest bottom belief system
is a fear of more mortality
and when that moment of like I can't die
not as a devotional belief it had
nothing to do with that it was just a
mechanism I said oh my God I can't die
I tell you the same thing happened with
Savages me
tears started rolling down my face and
this Joy was an ache in my heart that
I've never experienced before I spent 40
years in my head that's how I became an
academic Mission and a research
scientist and when this moment hit it
was my heart that blew open I referred
to it as a heart orgasm and
and that was the first time I
experienced my heart as a as an
essential part of my own conscious
existence and what happened was
I was overwhelmed first with the fact
that I was not spiritual at 1 59 a.m and
at 2 A.M I was 100 spiritual you have a
very close friend you know your friend's
behavior and you happen to know your
friend's parent and at some point you
see that your friend shares the same
behavior as their parent so you you know
you casually volunteer you go you know
Bill you're just like your dad and
that's when you have to back away from
bill because Bill's the first guy that
says how could you compare me to my dad
and everyone laughs because they're
familiar but I say no there's two very
profound points from that one story and
profound Point number one everybody else
can see that bill behaves like his dad
he got his programming from his dad it's
only Bill who doesn't see it and
profound Point number two we're all bill
because all of us got programming and
all of us operate with these programs
and we don't even see we're doing that
we even when told we're doing it will
deny that we do these behaviors because
we don't even see what we're doing
that's why it's called subconscious
below conscious when I first started
talking about it it was from an academic
conscious point of view this is what I
learned but my subconscious programs are
still exactly the same so well I had
this wonderful knowledge my life still
wasn't anything I wanted to to brag
about it because it wasn't and and as
you know that old gamer who would you
like to be and I could think of anybody
I'd rather be than me And yet when I
started to apply the new science and
rewrite the subconscious so it supported
me rather than the programs of
limitation or disempowerment that we get
from our parents and our community as
children which almost all of us get when
I put in the new programs all of a
sudden I started to find my goodness my
life completely turned around uh all
wonderful things started happening in my
life I was healthier I haven't been to a
doctor in 20 years I I don't need that I
don't take any of their drugs why
because most of the illness is just from
the stress of not living in Harmony and
when you learn to to get rid of the
limiting programs that we got as
children and put in programs that
support you guess what then all of a
sudden the place turns into heaven uh
and it's interesting to people I tell
people will you create your own life and
then they look around and go I don't
want responsibility for this but I say
well you didn't know you were creating
with these unconscious beliefs and and
yet then I tell people especially people
that have fallen in love and people have
fallen head over heels in love I said go
back to that time when you first fell in
love let me ask you a question were you
healthy and oh yeah I was I was healthy
as anything I said you have energy I
said oh I had so much energy made love
for days in a row without even eating
and I go yeah and I go uh and how was
life for you it was so exciting I
couldn't wait for the next day so I said
in this little period that you you know
that I refer to as a honeymoon I say
wasn't life like heaven on Earth and
they go well yeah and I go you know that
was not an accident that was an actual
creation and you say but what was
different that made life uh uh so heaven
on Earth during love and the answer is
because you become very self-conscious
of yourself you don't rely on the habits
the day before you meet this person
you're going to go on a date I say
especially the women I say how long did
it take to get dressed and they say well
it was 15 minutes and I was out of the
house and then I say now tonight you're
going to go on a date with this person
who has just rocked your world and I
said how long does it take you to get
dressed it's like my God it may take an
hour or two and I said yesterday 15
minutes today an hour or two what's the
difference yesterday I got dressed by
habit because I get dressed every day
but tonight I am looking in the mirror
meaning I am self-conscious I am making
sure that I represent myself to be the
fully the best individual I can be and
when both parties are not relying on the
habit and both of them are saying I'm
creating the best I can be they're
living in the moment of them now they're
being very mindful they're being very
present and guess what
heaven on Earth is created how many
people may think well hold on a second
so I can take five minutes and I can
totally change my life and that's all I
need and I think that's a really a
wonderful possibility but the
probability is this are you going to hit
the right statement that is the one that
you need to change your life okay uh
let's say someone's overweight and they
say in their mind I I am you know a
weight a number they like I am 125
pounds and you're not uh and I say uh so
I want to change my weight and I put a
program in I'm going to lose weight
and I go but wait that extra poundage uh
that might be due to protection okay
what do you mean if eyes as an as a
young person was abused then the
Consciousness is if I'm a heavy person
they won't bother me anymore and so the
weight isn't due to just eating food the
weight is due to I'm safer being heavy
than I am I say well if you want to
change your weight you can talk about
the weight all you want but until you
adjust the problem from the the fear uh
you know that I'm going to be abused
that's where the problem came from it
didn't come from eating food over here
so I said yeah well you can change
beliefs uh sometimes I like to give a
visual a matter of fact I visualize a
big spider web which has like circles
and then lines coming out you know like
a web okay and so there are links as you
go around there's also anchors where the
web is anchored at a couple of places
and I go each belief is like a link
and that spider weapon you can do one
link on another link and another link
I'll really change this by your web but
if you do a belief that is an anchor and
you change the anchor belief and that
anchor lets go
the web will collapse that's possible
the point is this sometimes a police
statement knocks out a link
but when you really hit it just right
you knock out a support and when you
knock out a major support the whole web
collapses instead of just a link at a
time which could take it down but it's
much harder in our mind we start to
realize that we're concerned we're
afraid we don't have enough I'm not safe
I'm not secure and I say oh these
thoughts I was talking about the
thoughts in your mind go in and control
your biology your genetics your
physiology and your health and I go yes
this is really true I said well how can
I tell you what your thoughts are in a
sense that can I read your thoughts and
I say yes you know I could put wires on
your head and it's called
electroencephalograph and I could read
your brain activity and I go oh great I
can see this brain activity
I want to tell you something that's
profoundly important
we were programmed to believe that our
thoughts are contained in our head that
if I have a thought it's just for me not
for anybody else it's inside and it's
working through me
and now I want to tell you about a new
technology it's not
electroencephalograph it's called
magnetoencephalograph I say what's
unique about that I say it reads your
brain I say yeah but so does EEG I say
yeah but EEG would put the wires on the
head and you get the electrical activity
conducted through the skin from the
brain and that's what I'm reading and I
said what's different about Meg
the probe is out here
and I said what does that mean
your thoughts are not contained in your
head your thoughts are broadcast to the
field just like a radio broadcast I said
well what if I as an individual have a
thought that says let's have peace in
the world
and I broadcast out there in the street
and I say let's have peace and I look
around it's like where's the piece I
don't see the peace and here's what the
relevance is
each of us is broadcasting
if you get enough people
to have the same thought
that broadcast is Amplified
each of us has a small power
but if you put a thousand people the
same thought ten thousand a hundred
thousand people with the same thought
you are broadcasting a most powerful
thought not just in your body but out in
the field I say your Energy's in the
field the thought is in the field and
you go well what does that mean and then
I'll give you this most wonderful quote
I used it the other day in a lecture
from Albert Einstein
and the quote is so important here's the
quote
the field so a definite definition the
field is the invisible energy right now
you're in a field there's cell phone
broadcast television television radio
broadcast all kinds of information
coming across but guess what each one of
you is a broadcast in that field the
quote the field
is the sole governing agency of the
particle
particle is the material Realm
so what was Einstein saying it's the
energy in the field that shapes the
physical experience of our lives and if
enough of us collectively have an energy
that's coherent and strong and we
broadcast the belief we change the world
I just want you to recognize as much as
I wanted peace in the world if not
enough people are out there saying let's
have peace in the world there is no
peace
if I want to say let's have a war how
can you have a war you have to have
enough people convinced that the war is
going to benefit them so that their
broadcasts say yes let's have a war
because I and my colleagues we're all
going to have a better result from that
and the reality is this
the only things that change on this
planet collectively are when we
collectively share thoughts
and yoga when you're in your postures
when you're in your process your mind is
sharing a thought not just in your head
but all around you so the whole idea
about this is we have to recognize we
are collectively creating reality with
our thoughts
and if we want to change reality it can
change instantly
the moment we become coherent the moment
we collectively are on the same platform
of thinking you get enough people to say
peace there will be peace instantly in
this world
but we've been programmed by other
people to give them the power to tell us
what we need
and Assad Fiji has been telling us so
importantly what we need is not what
they tell us what we need is what we
know
and I really hope that you understand
this because when you have your thoughts
recognized it's not contained in your
head your thoughts out in the field and
that thought the field is the soul
governing agency of matter
and therefore what this world is looking
for at this moment is an evolution it's
not an evolution of our biology our
biology has already evolved
it's an evolution of our consciousness
when we collectively as a population say
enough is enough it will end they will
have approximately 50 trillion cells in
our body and these cells are all
self-sufficient they have their own
memory they have their immune immune
system and in fact you're also going to
say that for 2.75 billion years there
was only one celled organisms alive on
the planet yeah and the nature is as the
Single Cell evolved to be the most
intelligent and could be it ran into a
physical limitation because intelligence
is physically tied up with the membrane
or skin of the cell you can only have so
much membrane so Evolution apparently
stopped it was like two and a half
billion years just a single cell
organism then I said well how can you
have more Evolution the answer is cells
decided to come together in community
because when cells come into Community
they share awareness so there's more
awareness with 10 cells than there is
with one cell and there's more awareness
with a million or a billion or a
trillion so when you look at a human
being while we see ourselves as single
entities the truth is we are made out of
50 trillion amoeba like cells and so our
bodies this giant community and what
makes it very exciting as you mentioned
is well in my own work with cloning
cells I can take a cell out of your body
and could live outside of you why it has
its own intelligence it has essentially
every function in your body is present
in a Cell so my seven-year-old Vision
manifests to be true when I got older to
realize cells are Miniature people and
then you say well what about happens in
the human body and I go this is where
the issue comes in is because you have
50 trillion cells living in community
but your mind is the government when a
government works in harmony with the
people then the people thrive and the
community is is in good health and grows
but when a government is not really
supportive or not working in in harmony
with a community then the government can
cause the the the nature of that
Community to fall apart and even lead to
to the end of the community well that's
what we're finding out our mind is the
government and when we entertain Harmony
and and the right living and balance
with nature and with each other then we
provide our 50 trillion cells with very
life-supporting information and
chemistry so Harmony means
giving the body good food yes not being
stressed out absolutely living in a in a
happy environment yes basically it says
uh it's as I said when I had my petri
dish of cells if I put it from a healthy
environment to a bad environment the
cells got sick but you didn't have to
give them drugs uh but all you did is
take the the dish from the bad
environment and put it in a good
environment and the joke which I like to
tell people is well this happens in the
plastic petri dish but guess what we are
skin covered petri dishes underneath our
skin is 50 trillion cells living in
addition the culture medium is the blood
and so when I change the culture meaning
in a plastic dish I changed the fate of
the cells and I say well then what
controls the culture medium my blood the
chemistry and the answer is my thoughts
influence my brain and the Brain
releases chemistry that matches my
thoughts so when I'm in stress or I'm
afraid of the world I release different
chemistry into the blood than if I open
up my eyes and I find myself in love I
release completely different chemistry
and it's like well all I have to ask in
individual is how do you feel when
you're in total love or how do you feel
when you're in fear and the answer is
well I feel totally different guess what
all the cells are bathed in that
chemistry and so the the feeling of Love
produces totally different chemistry in
the blood chemistry that supports growth
and healing of the body and supports the
immune system and in contrast when we
perceive reasons to be afraid and we
release stress hormones into our body we
actually shut off the growth mechanisms
and the immune system to serve to save
the energy why because if you believe
you're going to have to run from that
lion you want all the energy available
to run from a line so when a person is
in stress they allocate their energy
reserves for fight or flight but take it
at the expense of the health of the
system the immune part of the system and
so the more stress you're under the more
bad chemistry in a sense of not
supporting you you that you experience
uh and and it was a very important point
in our Evolution stress or fear was not
the main stay of Life the Mainstay of
life was to be happy and live in the
harmony of the environment every now and
then a saber-toothed tiger would come
okay now it's time to be stressed out
now it's time to run but the point is
once you escape from the saber-toothed
tiger in the old days and it's like oh
back to health and Harmony and I said
what about today's world today's world
is 24 7 run from the tiger and this is
not biologically sustainable because uh
the chemistry of protection uh contrasts
with the chemistry of growth
you in here duck
hello
doc yeah it's Marty where are you
oh okay yeah yeah I'll be right there
doc duck
duck where are you
ready I'm here it's pouring rain out
here just wait just wait two more
seconds
oh oh no oh
Marty Marty Marty we gotta Get Back to
the Future what happened to the DeLorean
oh I couldn't keep up with the payments
during the pandemic but hey this is a
good baby
all right all right
Marty Marty we have to go back to the
future right now Doc the seems very
uncertain I don't think we should be
going to the Future right now you're not
thinking fourth dimensionally get in the
car I'll explain it to you when we get
there all right
foreign
doc where are we when are we Marty just
look at the inboard monitor down there
and what you can see is we are in
between time we're moving from an old
civilization and we're moving through
time into the future of a new
civilization
wow this looks pretty chaotic and random
is that normal well actually it's not
random and you're right it is chaotic
because chaotic has pattern even though
you can't see it and if you want to know
what the pattern is look the old
civilization is coming down and as it's
coming down the pieces are forming a new
civilization that is rising up and we
are now in the middle so it's not random
so this is all just a big illusion well
it is an illusion because once you think
the world is made out of matter and
energy that's a false understanding but
now quantum physics revealed there is no
separation of matter and energy atoms
which make up matter are energy so
everything is an illusion reality is an
illusion albeit a persistent one
so you're telling me that the future
changes depending on the field that we
have intentions for well absolutely the
reason is this because as the planet
moves through the solar system and the
universe the energy surrounding this
planet changes that's the field and when
the field changes the matter changes so
we're in a process of evolution moving
from an old structure into a new
sustainable world to understand what I'm
talking about Marty look at the inboard
monitor there I can show you about the
signs called cymatics that's the science
of how vibration and energy and feel
shapes matter
as you can see how it works you sprinkle
particles on a metal plate and then when
you play a vibration and energy field
through that plate the vibration causes
the particles to jump around and form a
pattern but when you change the
vibration the old pattern falls apart
and simultaneously a new pattern is
emerging this is exactly where we are
today in Planet Earth
wow doc that is sick sick Marty I don't
know what you kids are talking about
everything is sick no we're moving into
the future where everything is health
and Harmony and love hold on Marty
you want to change the world we don't
have to physically go out and physically
change the world first first we have to
change our belief about the world our
belief of who we are in the world we're
not victims but we've been programmed to
believe we're frail vulnerable that
we're victims of the world and the fact
is no we are the most powerful beings
and entities on this planet we want to
get out of the box think out of the box
and that will change all of it what you
we would see from a new understanding of
evolution which is a great extension
beyond the darwinian belief belief which
is quite limiting okay and quite
Troublesome in fact uh because just
think about what the principle darwinian
belief is that evolution is based on a
struggle for survival with a competition
for Fitness so that says oh my God then
our world is we're all out there and a
dog eat dog Rat Race trying to survive
because if you stop running the person
behind you is going to run over you so
if that's your way of life then every
day by definition and you are living in
a stress hormone body because of all the
fears that we that we have and yet
Evolution says no evolution is based on
community and cooperation a body has 50
trillion citizens they live in harmony
with each other and it turns out that
every human being we're beginning to
find out is like a cell in a larger
Community called Humanity so in
biological terms the organism that's
evolving on the planet is not the human
being we already did that the organism
that's evolving is the super organism
called human civilization and right now
humans are fighting each other and
killing each other and if I say well
what would that look like inside the
body if the cells fight each other and
kill each other and I say oh well that's
called autoimmune disease
self-destruction and and autoimmune
disease can kill you from the inside and
that's on the increase isn't it oh
absolutely because because our
biological lives are complements to the
environment The more stress and more
violence on the outside the more that's
taken inside in biology and converted to
uh disruption and disharmony of your own
cellular internal Community if you can
create a honeymoon for yourself while
you're in love and everyone started to
create a honeymoon for themselves then
all of a sudden the concept of war and
violence would disappear because if
everybody's in love and everybody's in
Harmony and everybody's so excited by
being here then the competition and
violence that we live by because of
today's beliefs would disappear as you
understand the terms quantum physics and
quantum mechanics or Newtonian physics
and Newtonian mechanics what you see is
that physics and mechanics are synonyms
so physics really means the mechanisms
by which the universe operates and the
new physics quantum physics was
something that I really wasn't into nor
were any of my colleagues in the medical
school we were all trained in Newtonian
physics and the difference between the
two is very profound Newtonian physics
says the world that we live in the
Universe we live in as a machine made
out of mechanical Parts if you want to
understand how it works take it apart
study the pieces change the pieces
change the operation That's the basis of
medicine we look at a human body it's a
machine made out of physical parts when
it's not working right change the parts
by buying chemicals and drugs and that's
the way that conventional medicine
operates when I started to read the
quantum physics I realized oh my
goodness the the whole foundation of the
universe is not based on a mechanical
physical Universe it's based on the
invisible energy called the field so
let's say if I hold a magnet right here
in front of you and you can see the
magnet but what you can see is the
invisible magnetic field and so what it
says is well we are physical things in
our world like physical bodies we're
immersed in fields electro magnetic
fields magnetic fields itself all kinds
of fields like telephone cell phone
Fields television Fields radio Fields
whole ranges
what is the difference between the
Newtonian physics and the quantum
physics is this Newtonian physics focus
on the particles quantum physics says
you want to understand why the particles
take this shape then you have to
understand the field it's the field that
controls biology it's the invisible
forces there's a great quote by Albert
Einstein and it's simple it goes the
field is the soul governing agency of
the particle in other words in the world
of invisible things fields and particles
matter
it's the field that gives shape to the
matter and this is the basis of quantum
physics this becomes relevant it says
okay here's the physical particles of my
body why are they in a healthy state or
why could they be in a sick State that's
the physical expression and the answer
is well to understand that don't look at
the body you have to understand the
invisible forces in the field
and it's fun because if you think about
when when of course when you were young
at some point you must have had like
iron filings and sprinkled it around a
magnet and all of a sudden you saw the
iron filings form that pattern of the
magnetic field
well quantum physics would look at this
pattern and try to explain how come all
the iron filings fell in this pattern
without recognizing that the field
exists in other words can you explain
why the iron filings have this shape if
you don't recognize a magnetic field the
answer is absolutely not what's the
nature of it the body and its cells are
like iron filings medicine is trying to
understand the nature of the body by
looking at the iron filings and quantum
physics says if you don't understand
that invisible field you can't ever
understand what's happening in the body
the cells in your body are covered up by
the skin disconnected from the
environment but in order to survive
these cells have to adjust their
genetics and their behavior to adapt and
maintain their survival in a changing
environment so the question is then how
do the cells inside your body actually
know what's going on in the real world
because they're not connected to it I go
this is the role of the nervous system
the nerve nervous system's job is to
read environmental signals and then
relay those signals into the cell so as
Illustrated right here we are getting
signals from two different environments
in our body signals from within our body
as well as signals from without our body
and the function of the nervous system
is to read both of these environments
the relevance is the nervous system
reads the information in the environment
and then translates it into signals that
are sent to the 50 trillion cells inside
your body to alert them to what is going
on in that world so in fact that is a
true statement the environment is
controlling the behavior of your cells
but the Mind does an interpretation of
those signals based on our life
experiences now for a lot of people this
seems difficult but let's put it in a
different context because we can talk
about computers there's a very
interesting fact about our brain as a
computer because it has an autocorrect
mechanism built into the subconscious
meaning what well I can have my
conscious mind like typing on the
computer about what's going on in the
world
but if I type something that signal can
be translated and sent to the cells but
if I type something that the
subconscious has no recognition of it
will do like an autocorrect and change
what I wrote to fit something that it
thinks that I wrote as a subconscious so
I put in a love and subconscious changes
that to live that's a whole different
meaning at this point because of
misinterpretation so the point is
your wishes and desires of your
conscious mind are filtered by the
programs in your subconscious mind and
if you have a wish or desire that
doesn't conform to a program that
already exists then the subconscious
mind's job is to re-translate that into
something that makes sense for the
subconscious belief not for the
conscious so we may have wonderful
wishes and desires and if it doesn't
conform to the programs that we receive
the subconscious will change those into
something it understands to make sense
out of what I've just said consider
using your cell phone that you write
something in your cell phone such as
let's put the word epigenetics in the
cell phone and I go when I type
epigenetics in the database in the phone
says I don't know that word at all and
then what does it do it throws up
different options that could be closely
related to epigenetics and so the
significance is if I put something into
my system that is not supported by the
program then the programming system will
change whatever I did to accommodate
what it believes is right now the issue
about this is well if I want to have
epigenetics in my phone then what I
really have to do is open up my
dictionary and add the word epigenetics
and now after that anytime I write
epigenetics the phone mechanism will
understand what I'm talking about well
going into the database and changing the
program is the function of what energy
psychology is all about it says if your
behavior is not conforming to your
wishes and desires then it will be
necessary to go into your program and
install new behaviors that you want to
manifest so now the brain will have a
reflection or resource of what you're
talking about so I really want to
emphasize the nature of biology belief
is different than the fact that just
environment controls your genes and I'll
give a very simple example of what I
mean by that but the fact that I can
have two people and the Very exact same
environment
but each of these individuals has a
totally different reaction to the
environment
so if it was just environment that
controlled your genes and your behavior
then both individuals should have exact
same behavior
but the reality is no the two people
have different responses to the
environment I go why same environment
but their minds have different
interpretations and it's the
interpretation of the mind about that
environment that is sent to the cells so
the important part is this yes
environment controls epigenetics
there's an external environment
but an internal environment
Annette recognized in humans the
internal environment is not a direct
readout from the external world it's an
interpretation of that external world
and that's why each of us has a
different response to the world in which
we live and that is why the biology of
belief is an extension of the foundation
that environment controls at the
genetics you can change the programming
you can rewrite your subconscious
programs and why is that relevant
if you took the wishes and desires of
the conscious mind and use that as a
program to put the beliefs into the
subconscious mind it's the most exciting
and liberating thing you can ever do in
your life you know why because once it's
in the subconscious program 95 of the
day without you even thinking about it
your mind will take you to that
direction
and that is your freedom everybody's
mind is like attuning Fork because
actually you can read brain activity
from outside your head with a new thing
called magnetoencephalograph most people
are familiar electroencephalogram put
wires on your head and read your brain
function the new one
magnetoencephalograph they put a probe
out here and they can read your brain
function from outside well it's a very
important point he says well if you're
reading my brain function from outside
then what am I doing I must be
broadcasting my brain function so all of
us are like tuning Forks but if we're
all out of tune then there's a tendency
for even a tuning forth that tries to
stay in tune will be pushed Out Of Tune
by something we call entrainment and the
issue is
how can you survive in this world the
answer is you must essentially detach
yourself from this field around you not
be taken in by the stories not be buy
into the fear not to buy into the
threats on our existence and start to
recognize look we are creating these
lives if you buy other people's creation
then you manifest what they're creating
if you want what you want then you have
to not get engaged and the more
conscious you become the less you are
affected by the outside fields and so
this Rising Consciousness that we're
seeing is the evolution of humanity to
rise above the noise of the background
and recognize you're the Creator we also
bought this and it's not true
that there's somebody in the
subconscious meaning if my conscience
finds my subconscious engaging in some
Behavior it's not supporting it then my
conscience is talking to myself and my
conscience saying Bruce God that was
stupid you could do better than that and
you're having this inner dialogue and
you're talking to yourself and being
very upset about the fact that your
behavior seems to be out of control
who are you talking to
and I love this because the reality is
we're thinking we're talking to
ourselves and that's going to fix
something and what is it going to fix
well the program's in that subconscious
and here's where the problem lies
subconscious is a tape player there's
nobody in there you the the the same
exact truth holes in this case get a
tape player put a cassette tape in it
push play the program's running and you
don't like the programming so here's
what I want you to do go up and talk to
the tape player go up and talk to it
suggest that it changed the program even
tell it what you wanted to play do it do
all this and then you realize the
program's still plays it doesn't change
and then you get more upset with
yourself why because you've asked this
program to change it's not changing yet
then you get mad at yourself you start
yelling at yourself and you're berating
yourself because you can't control the
tape then that doesn't work and then of
course the last step you have to bring
God in because obviously you tried a
change your life and it didn't work so
only God has to come in here now and
change the tape and and the joke is
how much talking to a tape player does
it take before the tape changes the
answer is you can talk to your blue in
the face and it will not change it's not
that you can change the tape but you
have to learn how to push the record
button
and then you can record new programs in
the subconscious but our old belief
system like conventional psychology
let's go over and find out why my life
is this way oh yeah my mom did this to
me and my dad did this and my friends
did this and now I make a whole list of
all the reasons why my life is this way
I'm very clear my conscious mind's got
oh God I could play that movie I can see
it the question is now that you're aware
did it change the tape player the answer
is no and that's why people get so upset
they they go through all of the
psychology counseling and stuff they
know all the reasons they still have the
same life so the issue is you want to
make change
then you have to learn how to engage the
tape player in a record mode and not
just talk to it being a biologist I want
to talk about a different aspect of
service but it's the same thing because
my dear friend saviji was talking about
service and how we can influence the
world around us I want to give you an
interesting biological insight about
your own personal consequence of being
in service and basically it has to deal
with the DNA in your cells I say what
does that mean I say well the DNA is the
genetic code I say and every time the
cell divides
you have to copy that code
and so if I can try to make an image
with my hand here imagine my arm is the
DNA
and I say it's time to copy it there's a
protein so let's say the microphone okay
thank you that my arm my hand is the
copying device it's like a train on a
railroad track as the train moves down
the DNA it leaves behind a copy of the
DNA it just wrote over I say well that's
really cool except guess what when the
train gets to the end of the DNA
it can't copy the part where the train
is sitting on it so it copied everything
all the way up to here but can't copy
this piece so when I copy it the new
piece is shorter than the original piece
and so every time you copy every time
the cell divides the DNA gets a little
shorter than it did before and I say
well why is this relevant because if you
make a shorter piece of DNA when you
copy it then every time you copy it
you're interfering with the genetic code
so it's like well nature would say oh my
God if every time the cell divides
pretty soon I'll chop that DNA up and
I'll have a problem
but nature of course being quite
intelligent adds a piece of DNA at the
end that is not the gene it's just an
extension it's called a telomere you may
have heard the word telomere and I say
what is it it's extra railroad track but
it's not the genes and I say why is it
relevant because every time I copy it I
lose a piece of the telomere but I
didn't cut into the genes and I say well
what's aging all about and here's what
we now know aging depression and disease
result when you copy the DNA so many
times that you run out of that track of
telomere and the next time you copy
you're cutting off the gene which
interferes with your biology so
originally it was thought oh the
telomeres have a fixed length and every
time it divides you lose a piece of the
length and the scientists back in the
60s Leonard hayflick calculated how many
times can a cell divide before it runs
out of telomere here and it came out oh
it was about 50 to 60 cell divisions I
say well why is that relevant because
our stem cells which Keep Us Alive when
they keep dividing what happens after
your stem cells went through 50 cell
divisions now your stem cells won't work
anymore and now you can't replace your
cells in your body and that's when they
said oh humans have a given lifetime you
know 90 100 years at Max and that's your
lifetime because that's when you run out
of telomeres
that was very depressing because it says
oh my God if I'm under stress I actually
cut the telomeres even faster The more
stress you're under the more it
disappears now and it was because of
again a woman scientist because they
always come up with the neat stuff that
the men are not looking at uh a woman
scientist found there was an enzyme an
enzyme called telomerase tilo enzyme
telomerase and I said what's that enzyme
it adds the length of the telomere so as
the cells are dividing if you can
activate this enzyme
it will extend the telomeres so the
cells have a relatively unlimited
lifespan
and so the relevance is the belief that
we only live of 100 years is mainly a
consequence of not being able to
continue to extend the telomeres in a
normal person so they start to find out
well what
influences the telomere
well the biggest thing is lack of love
if you don't if you have a lack of love
the feedback will shut off the
telomerase enzyme
if uh you have stress in your life
stress shuts off the enzyme if you have
no gratitude
or appreciation of life it shuts off the
enzyme why well if you don't like life
then why give you extra life that's the
enzyme is just responding but now it
comes down to the Opposites of those
love
at self-love which is most critical
is one of the the big drivers of
telomerase
gratitude and joy of being in this world
enhances the enzyme why if you love the
world you want more and the cells will
give you more
but now in a beautiful question
the most important contributor to
telomerase activity is service
that you are doing something on this
planet you have a mission to do
something and that your nervous system
is telling yourselves I'm not ready to
go I have a job to do and Caregivers for
example live an extraordinarily longer
healthier life than other people why a
caregiver's mentality is I have to
service and help these people and
therefore I cannot leave yet and I have
to be healthy the feedback from the
nervous system to the cells activates
telomerase so the simple line is this if
we have a mission and we have something
to do on this planet
you will activate telomerase service is
one of the primary things so it says if
you're just Meandering through the Earth
nice you're going to end around 90. but
if you're in service to the world you
can extend your life and right now
biologists somewhat agree that our
minimum lifespan is 140 years Medical
Science has revealed that from one-third
to two-thirds which is significant of
all healing whether it's drug related or
surgery or whatever healing process the
healing didn't come about from the
process the healing came about because
the person believed the process was
going to heal them so if I give you this
brand new drug and it's purple colors
because that makes it really special you
know and it's funny because there is a
drug a purple drug and I said it's
purple and everybody's like oh wow
that's got to be special but people
believe that the drug holds this effect
and you give a person this drug and all
of a sudden they heal themselves and
they say yeah the drug did it and then
you tell them later but it was just a
sugar pill that that healing didn't come
from the drug it came from the belief in
the drug so the belief in
yeah it's again the power of belief in
this case it's a very positive belief
that this procedure drug or whatever is
going to heal me but what people haven't
talked about because everyone knows
about the placebo effect is that
the placebo effect on it is based on a
positive thinking what is the
consequence of negative thinking ah well
science has a term for it but it hasn't
really come out in the public it's
called the nocebo effect and the nocebo
effect has been revealed by science that
a negative thought can not only make you
ill but a negative thought could also
kill you you can be scared to death in
us in a real sense okay and and why is
that important because it turns out it's
not just the positive thought of placebo
that's influential the negative thought
works the same way with the same power
but in the opposite direction so
basically it's not Placebo no sibo it
comes down simply this it's the power of
thought and a positive thought will move
you in a healing Direction and a
negative thought will move you into an
illness Direction but before I get off
that topic I don't want people to go out
there in the audience and go oh oh one
of those positive thinking kind of guys
is like it's more than just positive
thinking it's a commitment and an
intention of positive thinking it also
really needs the support of your
subconscious belief because if your
subconscious belief is going oh that new
wage weirdo stuff if that's what your
subconscious is programmed to believe
and yet your conscious mind is the one
that says I will think positive thoughts
and I go back to the data only five
percent of your life is coming from the
conscious mind so if you're only
entertaining A positive thought with
your conscious mind you're only
contributing five percent of that to
your life 95 of your life is still
coming from the subconscious and if the
subconscious doesn't hold those beliefs
then you're actually fighting yourself
and not likely to realize the expression
of a positive thought you have to wake
up to the reality folks that you're all
a bunch of weak and vulnerable people
when it comes to what's outside there
the sky is literally falling reports
from Australia have come in that
everybody that walked outside their
survival shelter was literally crushed
by the skies aimed down upon them the
ones beautiful at Green Hills of the
countryside have become a Barrett
Wasteland not to mention a band of
unruly Sorcerers and bewitched the Land
There are even reports of animals taking
up arms walking on two legs
B is a pain it is my job to keep you
informed of all the latest horrible
things going on out there I'm just
trying to protect you I can't take any
more of this I can't I can't watch this
anymore
oh
no more water
no more food
how am I gonna survive in here
but I can't go out there
I can't survive in here
I can't survive out there
what am I going to do meet Bruce Lipton
portrait of a man paralyzed by fear
the lowly cellular biologist has been
hiding away in his survival shelter for
more days than he can count
and the apparent Terror that Reigns
outside the doors of his Rusty shed
presents a limitless degree of Terror in
his mind
however there is one problem that takes
center stage on this inauspicious day
Bruce has run out of food and water
question of how to survive in a state of
chronic protection lingers ever so
greatly
what you are about to witness is a
strange sort of Mortal Combat between a
man and his beliefs
in the Twilight Zone
entering a new reality of Mind unlock
your potential with the key of
imagination
a realm of ever-changing perceptions
a world of quantum physics beliefs and
miracles you have just crossed over into
the Twilight Zone
I've got no more water and I've got no
more food I can't survive by staying in
protection in order Survivor have to go
out because I can grow on the outside
and I can't go out there because there's
so many scary things out there that can
threaten my life but
wait a minute
ah it was in quantum physics yes quantum
physics the most valid science on this
planet
oh here it is
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences
wow
I have to have a different Consciousness
I can't be afraid because the stress
shuts off my immune system and the
stress shuts down my growth and
maintenance of my body I have to change
that Consciousness I can't be in fear I
have to recognize how powerful I am I am
a co-creator of the world I am strong I
am healthy I have to maintain this as a
way of life a belief system before I go
out there
but now that I'm aware
I no longer fear going out there
the world can often present us with a
frightening reality but sometimes the
fear we experience only exists in our
minds and now for Bruce beer only exists
in the Twilight Zone you as an identity
are in your conscious mind you actually
are in there that's where your personal
identity is
and we have a tendency to say if I talk
to myself I'm going to give myself a
good talking to and I'm going to change
that subconscious I say to myself Bruce
don't do that again do this don't do
that again and and then I say it's very
frustrating why you can talk until
you're blue in the face
and nothing will change I say why and
the answer is and this is the most
important part
there is nobody in the subconscious
there's nothing there it's a machine
it's a record playback device so you can
talk to the machine as much as you want
if you don't know how to push the record
button nothing's going to happen so that
I say how do you change the program I
say how did you get the program the
first seven years your brain was in
Theta hypnosis
so I say you want to change a program
every night when you go to bed just as
your mind disconnects just as you fall
into sleep your brain is now operating
in Theta so if you put earphones on your
head
and you play a tape a program a CD of
what you want
as your your conscious mind disconnected
your subconscious is downloading so you
just play that tape as you go to bed and
after a number of playings your
subconscious will learn the new program
without even your conscious being
involved that's number one after age
seven how do we put a program in
repetition how did you do anything you
repeated it over and over again how long
did it take you to learn the alphabet
how many times did you have to go from A
to Z before you could remember the whole
alphabet when you drove a car you didn't
know how to drive a car until you did
what you practiced you repeated so if
you want to change a program you put
into your mind a repetition and it's not
it recognizes what you want to change
doesn't exist so when you put in the new
program it'll sound strange so let's say
you are sick you have a disease and I
say what program do I want I am healthy
I go it doesn't sound right I know I'm
sick I say I don't care there's a saying
in English fake it until you make it
what that means is if you want to be
happy just keep in your mind I am happy
I smile even if you have to force a
smile I am happy I'm smiling I say
repeat this and repeat this and guess
what after a short time it becomes a
habit
and when you're in that habit you don't
even have to think I am happy the new
habit will keep you happy all the time
because that's the new program someone's
not feeling well they've got
I don't know they've got the flu or
they've got someone with their stomach
or something what should they
practically do they should presumably go
to the doctor and get a diagnosis would
you go along with that I'm just I'm just
trying to see where this goes in
day-to-day life well I wouldn't say
don't go to a doctor but I say before
you go to a doctor just look around and
think about this what's going on in your
life where are the stresses coming from
because it's almost uh uh you're a
physiological expression is a compliment
to your life experiences those people
that are happy or healthy as I said when
you're in the honeymoon you didn't get
sick in the honeymoon that's when you're
absolutely healthy but when you got
caught back up into real life that's
when illnesses start to occur so we
always look at oh I must be sick there
must be something wrong with my biology
when it turns out it didn't begin with
your biology only about two percent of
illness is actually connected to
genetics let's say 98 of illness is not
just genetics it's environment so when a
person says I have the breast cancer
Gene and people think oh I'm going to
get breast cancer and I said well wait
wait 50 of women that have the breast
cancer Gene get cancer
what about the 50 that have the Gene and
didn't get the cancer and we never study
that side we only study the side that
got the cancer and you find out well
what is it that the 50
do that don't have the cancer yet have
the gene what's different the answer is
their lifestyle is different their
stresses their fears their concerns are
are not the same as the one that get the
illness the genes are like give you a
propensity to get a disease but that
propensity is based on how you perceive
life
uh and it's interesting uh studies show
that when children get adopted into a
cancer family the adopted child will get
the cancer with the same percentage of
probability as any of the natural
sibling and you say yeah but the the
child came from totally different
genetic stock and the point is yes it
wasn't the genes that promoted the
cancer it was the lifestyle that
promoted the cancer especially the
lifestyle of stress and then you say
well if stress is causing livestock I
could look around at the world I go my
God no wonder everybody's sick every day
is filled with more stress than the day
before and if you buy into the stress
you take that disharmonious vibration
essentially bring it in your life and
you end up with disharmony inside your
body your life is a reflection of what
you see we've been so programmed to
devalue ourselves and deep you know
disempower ourselves that we look at
ourselves as victims and frail
biological entities you know ripe for
bacteria to eat us up and all these
other things it's like this is totally
untrue so the issue is we have to start
from that belief and change these
beliefs of who we are we are profoundly
powerful people look you can walk across
hot coals you know a woman can lift a
car off of an infant without thinking
about it
down south the Baptist fundamentalists
of the Pentecostal Faith worked
themselves up in a Jesus State and drink
strychnine and toxic doses to
demonstrate that God protects them
they're not harmed by the strychnine I
mean you can walk across fire you can
drink poison you can lift thousands of
pounds where's the frail image come from
and that's a belief but the problem is
if you believe you are frail if you
believe you are susceptible if you
believe you have a terminal illness they
manifest because that's called the
nocebo effect they did a recent study
where they looked at some genes
controlling inflammation
and then they had they read the genes of
these people and then the people went to
eight hours of meditation and at the end
of eight hours the genetic activity was
completely changed in other words you
can change the genes in just eight hours
of a meditation and that means how
powerful your thought is in controlling
your biology I don't want to say don't
go to the doctor so I'll go back just 20
years ago the last time I went to a
doctor okay I went to a doctor because I
had pneumonia and I said to myself well
you know I can see why at that moment in
my life there was so much stress going
on in my life that I could see I was I
had opened my system up to that but then
I also realized okay well I can you know
handle this with my Consciousness but
then I realized the bacteria were
doubling and they're growing faster than
I can handle my Consciousness so I said
okay Now's the Time for some penicillin
but the concept of it was I don't rely
on the penicillin and and all I had to
say was look I get back on my feet and I
go it was my responsibility and if I
don't get into that same stressful
situation again then I won't have to go
through this again and it's been 20
years so it's intelligent learning yes
don't don't discard the element of
medicine until your Consciousness gets
high and the fact is when people have
lower consciousness
because they're not strong enough in
their Consciousness to really manifest
everything they want they really need to
take care of themselves more eat better
better nutrition do more exercises do
these things to add to your health but
the surprising thing is if you get more
and more and more conscious there's a
point where you get so conscious then
you become like the the person we refer
to as Jesus who does all these Miracles
and well and what did what what did
Jesus say about the Miracles he said
you could do these better than I could
do them but you don't believe and that
is the absolute truth because when you
fully have control of your consciousness
with that belief you do create the
Miracles the Miracles of spontaneous
remission for example a person
terminally ill who all of a sudden says
I'm not buying this I'm going to change
my vision of life and the moment they
change their perception they have what's
called a spontaneous remission again
that would be called a miracle but what
was it taking full control of
Consciousness and manifesting a life of
being fully conscious and present and
seeing what brings Harmony into your
life and avoiding or eliminating as best
you can any of the disharmony that
exists on the outside because disharmony
will make disharmony inside well I
probably don't have to tell you this if
you've been watching TV reading the
newspaper going online or even looking
out your window the world is in a state
of upheaval crises are all over the
planet crises based on economics
politics religion race are upsetting the
nature of civilization as we have known
it well this is not an accident actually
this is right on time on time yes we're
facing an evolutionary upheaval the
significance is profound science has
recognized that human behavior is
precipitating the sixth mass extinction
of Life on this planet five times in the
history of this planet life was thriving
in some event wiped out from 70 to 95
percent of all life the last time this
happened 66 million years ago a comet
hit the planet upended the ecosystem and
the dinosaurs disappeared forever well
guess what we are now in the sixth mass
extinction human behavior is causing
this the way out is to change Behavior
but to understand that we need to
understand that you are not a victim not
a victim of your dreams not a victim of
the world as quantum physics emphasizes
Consciousness is creating our life
experiences when I show up on September
27th in Copenhagen on Friday night I'm
going to provide a presentation to
inform you of why this upheaval is a
occurring the future of our Evolution
and more importantly how powerful you
are in creating the character of the
life you want as quantum physics the
most valid science on this planet
acknowledges Consciousness is creating
our life experiences well my
presentation will go deep into the
nature of Consciousness and how our mind
controls our genes controls the behavior
that we have and the life that we
express and when you understand that
you've been programmed and it's time for
us to get out of this program to
recognize how truly powerful you are
this is the opportunity to take charge
of your life and so what we need to
understand is this a you are not a
victim of your heredity because
epigenetics the new science reveals that
you are controlling your genetic and
behavioral activity and more so we want
to understand a very important fact
there's more to us in this physical body
that there's a field of energy with our
identity which is also recognized as a
spirit and if you recognize how powerful
you really are and that you are more
than this physical body you will have
the opportunity to take charge of your
life and create the wishes and desires
and aspirations that you seek the belief
that is taught is that biology in the
world we live in operates according to
Newtonian principles uh unfortunate part
about that is quantum mechanics 100
years ago said that's obviously not true
and physicists know this is not true and
yet medicine doesn't buy into it because
it still focuses on the material reality
and lets go of the invisible shaping
fields that quantum physics emphasizes
as primary okay so we got we have to
change that belief system we have to get
people to recognize that the field and
the thoughts and all these other things
are as important as anything else in
shaping the matter we live in uh number
two uh the belief which I you know I
blew away years ago but it's still being
taught in school is the concept that
genes control life
this is totally false genes control
nothing control is an action
a gene is a blueprint it's a physically
literally a string with blueprint data
on it why is that relevant well it's
interesting go to an architect's office
and the archetype's working on a
blueprint and then lean over the
architect shoulder and say is that
blueprint on or off and he looks at you
wait there's a blueprint's not on or off
it's a blueprint yeah but we talk about
genes being on and off like genes are
turning on and genes are turning off and
the question is but genes are blueprints
they can't turn on and off there is no
on and off it's just the blueprint it's
a pattern what we have failed to focus
on because we gave genes a character of
self-actualization that my genes decided
to do something it's like okay now we're
a victim of the genes but it turns out
biologists know that this is not true
biologists know that genes are not
turned on and off genes are red or not
red like blueprints then all of a sudden
it says well it's not the blueprint
that's important if the blueprints were
self-actualizing an architect could go
by a building site drop the blueprints
off come back two weeks later and the
building will be there that's what we
think about animals and plants the genes
are Blueprints and their control all
this is like no the blueprints are
important I'm not saying they're not you
got the bad blueprints you got some
problems going on here but the issue is
it's not the presence or absence of a
blueprint it's whether the blueprint is
being read and then you say well then
who reads the blueprint the answer is a
contractor
and who's a contractor the mind is the
contractor the Mind reads genes the mind
can change the genes read out here
here's something so blow away that most
people can't in their conventional World
make sense of it because it's it's like
ah it goes like this
the Mind through what is called
epigenetic mechanisms
can start with a single Gene blueprint
and create over 30
000 different versions of products from
the same blueprint thirty thousand
different products from the same
blueprint all of a sudden you realize my
God the you can infinitely vary the
expression of the Gene and the answer is
yes
and why is this become relevant to all
of us and the answer is because many of
us think genes control our lives and yet
we don't realize that we modify the read
out of the gene so we could be totally
healthy and our mind can cause cancer
our mind can cause any disease diabetes
anything like that and and what's
interesting is the flip side is some
people come here with actually defective
genes and guess what with their mind
they can rewrite those genes and make
them normal so the genes are not the
limiting factor it's the mind the simple
truth is
you cannot change anyone but yourself
and if you try and you start to realize
you put all that effort in to help
somebody and it doesn't come back
they're not affected by it you're the
one that's affected by it if you know
this the best thing to do is to
recognize you can be a model of what you
want
but you can't really make anybody else
unless they want it they will not change
so helping somebody only works if they
ask for the help if they don't ask for
that help that you're using up your
energy and it's not coming back and I
really feel that's the most important
thing because how frustrated we feel
when we know that somebody could do
better or be healthier and and you could
help them and they're not listening it's
not in their program at that time
when their program is ready to change
they will come to you and ask for the
help instead of us going to them it will
save your energy save your life and your
joy and you could use it to a much
better effect by creating an area an
aura an energy around yourself that
others want that
and then you will become the teacher and
that's what it's all about we talk about
again in in your first book about how
cells automatically move away from
toxicity and towards nutrition yes and
it seems that as human beings that's
something that we're trying to do but we
get it wrong a lot of the time we're
trying to move away from unhappiness or
what we think makes us happy and towards
what we think makes us happy but we get
it muddled up don't we well yeah but do
you see the key word here you said is
what we think makes us that's right so I
mean I was caught in that in the old
days too before I became aware I thought
at one point wow I'm going to buy that
little you know that car if I bought a
car that looked like a Ferrari called a
Pantera back in the 70s and I thought
okay I'm going to be happy I I got this
great car so I got the car in about like
three days later it's like now I got
this car I'm not any happier and a
matter of fact I got now three speeding
tickets because every day I took the car
out of course I couldn't go 30 miles an
hour with it so uh every day it was like
the car became a burden to me and it was
all of a sudden said well you know that
whole program that that Ferrari is going
to make you happy that that was a
misprogram it wasn't the car that makes
you happy and I started to find out it
wasn't the material things that make you
happy what makes you happy love makes
you happy good food will make you happy
Harmony in your environment makes you
happy these things are the harmony
environment where's the price tag on
that one you know basically having a
relationship with somebody that supports
you and fulfills you where's the price
tag we always bought the oh money gives
you happiness so we have all those
billions of people out there every day
running in the streets how much money
can I make because if I get enough money
I'm going to be happy and then you find
out even people the most money are not
happy and it was programming was wrong
if we were programmed to seek out
companionship and community and love
that's where you make us happy on a
beautiful spring day bill is celebrating
his 16 birthday and his father handsome
the keys to the car and says bill this
is your first solo trip please be
careful and enjoy this experience
thanks Mom
and for letting me use the car
he's very excited when he sees his
friends and waves hello to them being
the proud owner of a new driver's
license
hi miles hey I really like your new
electric train set
hi Gabe Lily Annabelle I want to come
and visit you tomorrow and jump on your
trampoline
oh this is so wonderful and he drives
down the street further and all of a
sudden something catches Bill's
attention
dad I take care of his car and the
engine lights flashing I don't know not
sure what it is Bill drives into the
local gas station where he sees the
mechanic there's a gas station I'm gonna
go in there
oh wow I'm lucky I made it into the
garage before anything went wrong with
the car wow Bill what seems to be the
problem here well hi Mr John I'm having
a problem with the service engine light
that's flashing I don't know what to do
about it well it'll let it be easy fix
you go wait in the waiting room and I'll
come and get you when the job is done
thank you Mr John my dad will be real
happy to have the car fixed bill goes
into the shop and the mechanic gets
behind the wheel
well it's the red check engine light for
sure and he puts his hand up under the
dashboard and he pulls out the light
bulb from the surface engine light
warning lamp oh I got a good idea
well that'll stop it from blinking for
sure
now the lamp isn't flashing anymore the
engine is running the car seems to be in
very good condition
wow the check engine light is off I'm so
happy Mr John fixed this car because Dad
would be very happy too happy to be a
service Bill he feels very happy and
excited about this because now he's
going off to finish a wonderful drive in
the country that he started a little
while ago but unbeknownst to Bill
problem has not been solved with the
issue in this car oh no oh no
this story is very profound because it's
a metaphor about life
consider your body as a vehicle such as
a car however instead of a dashboard
with lights on it we have emotions and
symptoms that Express how our vehicle is
running so we should recognize this when
we have feelings in our body and when we
have symptoms these are not negative
experiences these are very important
information providing awareness messages
these are messages that something is
going on in our body that we have to
deal with but by eliminating the symptom
we didn't eliminate the problem the
problem with the concept of power the
power of positive thinking is people
just think oh well if I just have
positive thoughts then my life should be
affected and and this is why positive
thinking has a real bad rap in the
public and the reason is this having a
positive thought does not in any way
necessitate that those positive thoughts
actually manifest themselves and there's
a piece that was left out and if you
don't understand the piece then you're
shouting into the wind with your
positive thoughts nothing's going to
happen and the fact is this
when you're having positive thoughts
you're using your mind
the new biology reveals that the
invisible forces that collectively we
refer to as mine that these form a field
which shape biology
well here's what's important yes the
Mind influences biology but there are
two parts to the mind that are
completely different than one another
yet they work together we confuse them
we tie them together and yet they
represent two entities working in two
different Fashions there's the conscious
mind and what is called the subconscious
mind
now here's what the very important
people have to know this okay and here's
what it is the conscious mind is our
creative mind that is connected to our
personal identity and our spiritual
selves that's that makes us all unique
or each of us has our own personal
conscious mind but what becomes very
significant is this is the subconscious
mind is equivalent to a tape player
that's exactly what it is it records
experiences and then plays them back
and and so now let's take a look and say
well wait there's a thinking mind and
then there's a tape player mind and
what's different about them is very
profound so let's talk about two
fundamental differences first
the tape player the subconscious mind as
an information processor as the
equivalent of a computer is a million
times more powerful on an information
processor than it's a conscious mind so
when you look at the power between the
conscious and subconscious subconscious
a million times more powerful
number two
on a date by day basis
the subconscious mind runs our biology
about 95 to 99 percent of the time
so while you're having all these
wonderful thoughts that's not the
conscious the conscious mind's not
running the show it's a subconscious
mind
then comes the issue is well the
subconscious mind got programs in it yes
and and the subconscious mind is not
evil or good the subconscious mind is a
tape player as much as you can say uh
okay here here's a tape player it's good
or bad so the tape player's not good or
bad
the programs can be good and the
programs can be bad so blaming the
subconscious mind as a negative thing is
that's the first mistake it's a tape
player
the programs that we got that's the
source of the problems that most of us
face and these programs could limit our
abilities and take away our powers which
essentially they do
now the relevance about positive
thinking is this
positive thinking is a creative thought
that comes from the conscious mind
okay so I sit here and I'm going to have
all these wonderful thoughts I'm going
to close my eyes and visualize all these
wonderful things now stop and go back to
the the mechanical character of it a I'm
having these thoughts with a little tiny
processor called the conscious mind and
I'm competing with the programs that are
in the subconscious mind
so if I have a thought for uh being
being healthy or being in a good
relationship
and I'm doing positive thinking and at
the same time I have acquired programs
in my development that said you're not
as healthy as you think you are and you
you're not that good a person to have
those kind of relationships then look
I'm now pitting my positive thoughts
against my programs and and they're in
their opposite
but this one works on a little tiny
processor and this processor is a
million times more powerful so right
away it's like who's going to win in
that challenge the answer of course is
subconscious gonna win okay but here
comes the other part
while I can try to maintain positive
thoughts in my life using my conscious
mind this conscious mind only operates
less than five percent of the day that
says 95 or more of the day I'm operating
from the other belief system
the point is do the math
how powerful or positive thoughts and
the answer is unless the subconscious
has the same programs and agreement as a
conscious mind power of positive
thinking will not work
it will not work because you're
competing against a much more powerful
processor when I finally started to
realize a very simple truth it was like
an old spiritual word but I now
understand the biological connotation of
it that we were made in the image of the
environment
and that so we are compliments to the
environment
and yet what we have done is without
being aware that our biology is
dependent on the environment that we
have systematically undermined destroyed
mother nature and Gaia and in the
process now we're finding we're we are
threatened with our own Extinction and
the fact is well we didn't know what we
were doing but the question is uh uh
well guy uh allow us to come back and
the answer is absolutely because just as
much as a person can come back from the
edge of death with something called the
spontaneous remission even though
science has already recognized we are
facing our Extinction so we could say
that we're a terminal patient
humanity is a dermal patient the concept
of changing our belief system
will allow the garden to come right back
to fullness again so we are in a
learning stage to remove ourselves from
the beliefs of our current civilization
which undermine not just the humans but
the environment that that we're in and
the problem is we were created as a
compliment to a certain environment
since we destroying or are destroying
that environment then we are no longer
compliments to an environment then we
don't fit by definition and that is why
the scientists recognize we are facing
our Extinction so
um I'd like to apologize to Nature
saying geez I'm really sorry we didn't
get it but we're learning and more and
more people especially the younger
people very importantly are recognizing
you cannot destroy this environment and
survive and that we must pull together
and honor Gaia the mother of us all
because by returning our love back to
Gaia guyo will give us back the love and
the life that we that we can have on
this planet I have a spiritual part and
I have a physical part
and I asked a simple question
why have a body
why don't I just be the spirit
and then this is what I found out I had
Jewish comedian cells
I asked a question of myself why have a
body why not just be a spirit and 50
trillion cells in my body welled up with
an answer and I said the answer what was
I said I asked a question the answer
came back in a form of a question that's
where the Jewish comedian guy came in
again I asked why have both a spirit and
a body and the cells answered with this
quote
Bruce
if you're just a spirit
what does chocolate taste like
and all of a sudden I said oh my God
that was the most profound thing in the
entire world I said why
because this is like a virtual reality
suit I can see with these eyes I could
smell I could taste I can hear and I go
so why is it relevant well as I said the
question came out if your spirit only
and sodva Jay and I are in the spirit
world and we're saying love is such a
beautiful thing it's a Harmony and a
connection and everything I said yeah
but what does love feel like you know
as a spirit how the heck do I know it's
but I say oh you have to have the
chemistry of the body and a nervous
system that translates the chemistry
into sensation sensation is not
chemistry it's electromagnetic vibration
it's a broadcast and I say so why is a
relevant so we had one little part I go
what we think our thoughts are in our
head and so we put wires on our head
called the electroencephalograph and I
can read your brain activity I go yeah
inside your head you've got all this
Consciousness going on and then I go you
know there's a new technology reads
brain activity as well it's not
electroencephalograph EEG
is called Magneto encephalograph m-e-g I
go so what's the difference they both
read Consciousness I go yeah what's the
difference
Magneto encephalograph the probe is out
here it doesn't even touch your head you
know stop I say why
you're reading my thoughts out here
and all of a sudden it's like my
thoughts are not contained in my head
no they're broadcast back to the field
I go I can read your thoughts from out
here so whatever you're thinking
positive or negative or the I can do
this I can't do that I said it's not
staying in here it's going out into the
world and the universe around us and
then I say so what's the relevance
there's something called resonance when
two things are in vibration if one
vibrates the other one will vibrate
okay and if they're not in Harmony One
vibrates and the other doesn't do
anything so I say so what does it mean
oh my God this is so changed life stuff
and I go my thoughts are vibration that
go out into the energy field which is
quantum physics I go so what I say
my thought will only vibrate and
resonate with something that matches the
thought
if I send out a thought of love
only elements that are in love that
vibrate within love will respond to my
thought because our We're In Harmony
we're in resonance
if I send out a thought of fear negative
and scare and I can't do this and I'm
afraid I said what do you think is going
to vibrate I say love is not going to
vibrate only things that you would be
afraid of things you would be you know
have fear over they'll vibrate and I say
so
put it all together
oh my God
we're creators
and we come in to this body to create
and that what we create and what we
experience is not kept in us our mind
translates it into electromagnetic
vibrations that go back to the field and
that integrates with our spiritual
vibration because they're the two in
resonance I'm in Resident with the
spirit and the spirit is in resonance
with the body why we're using the same
vibration so our lives make a difference
that we live here and I say what first
of all we're creators we're very
powerful I go until a Creator is
programmed not to be powerful and then
that Creator by programming will say
okay I'm not powerful and give up our
power
and we have been systematically
programmed to question who and what we
are one of the fact is we came here as
creators
I'm like well why did we come here for
the creation and I go because we get a
feedback that goes back to the source
that says what do you want and you come
here and try and create it and when you
find that love and when you find that
harm and you start to realize you're
glowing whether you're glowing your
energy vibration of Love is going back
to the universe to to resonate with you
and make you a stronger love vibration
when we were in that zero to six year
period every time we got sick we were
told we had to go to the doctor to get
healed that's that's an experiential
program so what does my subconscious
mind learn from this experience every
time I'm sick I have to go to the doctor
why apparently it's a step before you
get healed so we build that into the
program and then which is interesting is
that we have an innate ability to heal
ourselves that's what the placebo effect
is all about but when we put in a
program that says I have to go to the
doctor before I get healed then what you
do is actually stall your own ability
you to heal yourself until you go to the
doctor and the joke
many people get well on the way to the
doctor without having any treatment and
the reason is they already have the
ability to get well but the program
steps that until you do this next step
then the healing doesn't start so we
de-program our ability to heal ourselves
how many people go through the process
find it doesn't work and then repeat the
process and doesn't work again it's like
oh oh yeah I've been married four times
somebody was saying it's like God they
repeated the same error already three
times with the ideas do you think by the
fourth time maybe you could learn that
whatever pattern you played three times
in a row will probably play itself again
until you change not your partner you
keep bringing in the same partner with
different colored hair and a different
name but you're still you brought that
person in and you play the same game
over again the question is can you learn
the answer is you can but do many people
learn the answer is no because they keep
thinking that it's just my fate you know
that's just the way life is the
subconscious Still Remains unconscious
that's the problem woman until you
change the subconscious program you it's
the subconscious is a habitual mind it's
a habit until you change the Habit you
will be replay the Habit that's why it's
called a habit so you keep replaying the
same program it's like yeah you keep uh
you know it's like a definition of
insanity is the idea of keep doing the
same thing and expect something
different to happen the fact is though
that's insane why you keep doing the
same thing you're going to get the same
thing and if the Habit mind is giving us
a story then the answer says well how do
I change it answers change the
subconscious mind because that's where
the habits are that we got from other
people again this is most important the
fundamental habits and subconscious mind
came from other people and that's why
they rarely match what you want in your
conscious mind which is you
and you create those programs and yet
the fundamental programs and
subconscious were downloaded during that
first six years of our development this
is a truth
but if you really understand this truth
you have to change the way you are
living
because you're living by some
materialistic darwinian Newtonian give
me more matter I'll be happier and it's
like there's nothing to do with that at
all
because happiness is is not an object
and so what's a revolution well we've
been programmed on materialism
could be more matter
and it's like no because what do you get
I love it because we just like a
training session and there was this
professional wrestling
and his
Persona in the ring is like a bad guy
so he has to dress up and you know do
the acting and the wrestling
and everybody would boo-boo him that was
his job to be booed you know and he came
to psychic because he was really
depressed by it why because his job is
to be hated by people it's like well
that's not a great job but uh so we said
well what are you looking for he said
well
if if I could um maybe be an announcer
for this uh you know I could be an
announcer and then they said okay and
you get to be an announcer and what is
that what's that good for well if I get
to be announcer then maybe a network
will pick me up and then I could be a
sportscaster
oh yeah and then what he said well then
I'll have some more money and then what
so then five more things buy more things
that was it then I could buy some more
whatever he said and then and finally
you know we kept pushing to the last one
it was like and and what do you get from
getting this and finally after a litany
I'll be happy happiness I'll be happy so
uh remember Rob and I looked at him and
Rob says well you could be happy from
day one you didn't need to do any of
this stuff to be happy because even if
he actually did do all of this yes even
if you simply could say well that was a
circuitous route but at the end it did
bring happiness that would be different
but we know you go through this whole
circuitous route don't pick up at the
end you're still not happy no that's
what the rich people are they got all
this money but they're not happy and
it's like yeah well you could buy
anything you want it's like yeah but at
some point buying is not happy it was I
was happy to have it I said well happy
yeah it didn't have to be it happy could
be happy and uh but people have been
programmed
yes to conform to a machine
that requires some a to work and B
consumed work and consume work and
consume and that will make this machine
work like this we came here to create
we came here to experience love we have
a sensory system if it's not love it
takes us away from our creation we came
here to have the joy of what heaven on
Earth and all of a sudden say Earth is
heaven Earth is where you came to create
and then if you get misdirected in your
creation you can then create the world
that we have a world that doesn't look
that good to me you know uh and I guess
so why is this all relevant is because
we are truly powerful creators and we
have given up the belief that we have
any power at all I'm afraid of this I'm
afraid of that and I'm going well there
you go fear means close down growth is
open the opposite growth is to be open
and in love fear is to close down and
protection we cannot survive by closing
down anything that closes down will die
and so we have to it's the fear and then
I say so what about Bruce because you
might ask me that question
What stopped the fear in my life was I
owned my spirituality as a scientific
reality I didn't go through a devotional
phase not spiritual and then I had to
learn a lot of stuff and then I became
spiritual I was a biologist
and saw I am not in here I am a
broadcast and that moment of I cannot
die you cannot die you're not in there
but you have to not you know like have a
Devotion to spirituality it's either you
believe spirituality you don't believe
it and for me it wasn't a devotion it
was a scientific mechanism
and the relevance was the moment I saw
that my life just like boom what
happened I said I lost fear
and if you're not in fear no one can
control you
because fear is what makes you give up
the power to someone else something you
look at in spontaneous Evolution too is
how science and spirituality are coming
together they used to be very separate
usually absolutely the the scientific
World which is very factual driven and
that's that and you couldn't change it
and spirituality was trying to open up
things but they really are meeting now
aren't they yeah it was interesting
because the spiritual world of religion
was talking about the invisible moving
forces that shape the physical reality
and we call them spirit and then science
uh only came into existence because it
made a detaunt with the church in the
very early days of science it said look
we won't tread on your invisible
spiritual domain we will just study the
physical world and when Newton was able
to predict the movements of the planet
by just looking at the physical features
then science has got the ideas well if
you can understand how the universe
operates by just studying the material
where we don't need that invisible stuff
but 1925 Newtonian physics was
incorporated subsumed by a bigger
physics called quantum physics and
quantum physics emphasizes the universe
is made out of energy it's not made out
of matter and then I say well what does
the quantum physicist call this energy
that the universe is made of I say well
they call it the field I said what's the
definition of the field I love this
invisible moving forces that influence
the physical world I go my goodness
that's the same definition as spiritual
it's used for spirit I go yes quantum
physics emphasizing the invisible uh
field as primary to the physical world
is essentially reiterating the statement
of the spiritual people who talked about
the invisible forces shaping our
physical existence and so by definition
science the new science of quantum
physics is bringing us back into
alignment with the spiritual reality
hopefully the the dogmatic beliefs of
the church which had talked about these
wonderful terms but didn't allow us to
live there and science which is still
stuck in its material plane will both
divest themselves of their dogma and
allow us to come together and recognize
that we're all part of that invisible
field that that we don't even live in
our own bodies if you understand the
nature of how the cell works out we are
part of the field being downloaded into
our body that we're all by definition
the field or we're all spiritual same
definition and and if we recognize this
the unity of it and that you cannot be
taken out of the field and you cannot be
in a sense punished by the field you are
the field then maybe the beliefs those
very restrictive beliefs from both
science and from the dogmatic religion
uh will disappear but because the people
owning their own spirituality owning
their own responsibility and not saying
oh which spirits that did this or things
other factors that we are the creators
will generate a new world because what I
firmly believe is very simple go out and
talk to the average person anywhere in
the world and say if you could create a
world what would you like well I'd like
a world where there's peace and Harmony
and I like some food and a job and I go
isn't it amazing how everywhere you go
in the world virtually entire population
has the same belief I go then how come
we don't have any answers because the
leadership isn't exercising that belief
so I trust the people
to take over the leadership of this
world and that the structure that is is
actually in a state of collapse when it
collapses this will be our opportunity
to evolve from the very destructive
darwinian perception of a world
into a more holistic holism that says
we're all part of the same system we're
all cells in the same body and when we
work together we will create Magic on
this earth like nothing has ever been
seen before so I'm very optimistic about
that how do you rewire your brain well
as we just said the first thing you have
to do is say what the heck are my
programs you don't have to fix a program
if it works the only one you want to fix
is the one that doesn't work so they can
say well what are the programs and I can
already tell you the things that don't
work in your life that you desire to
have in your life and you are creating
an effort and a struggle and a lot of
work to make it happen the reason why
it's not working is because somewhere in
the program it doesn't support that
conclusion so this program does not
allow you to have this so the thing is
well as long as I have this program I'm
never going to get this and even if I
get it it's going to disappear if I you
know as soon as I let go of the control
it's going to disappear because sabotage
make it away so the first thing is
identify well where are you having
trouble
uh and I say whatever that destination
is that the thing you were looking for
whether it was a job Health relationship
whatever if that's where you're having a
trouble recognize this the program is
counter to that it's the opposite the
program is the opposite that's why this
can't stay here because this is going to
95 of the day create a different program
not the one you want it so I say so if I
have a troubled relationship then
basically uh my program for a
relationship doesn't work very well in
my case that was true I uh you know for
50 years I was operating from the
program of relationship that I
downloaded from my parents who had a
really sucky relationship it was so bad
and I was just manifesting it
unconsciously until I started a change
once I changed uh now I have heaven on
Earth I'm mad as heck but I will take it
anymore
we could be essentially unconscious
which most people are
and our lives look exactly the same why
because once you learn how to get
dressed you know how to get dressed once
you know how to drive a car you don't
have to be conscious how to drive a car
you already got the program so
everything that we learned in our
subconscious mind becomes automatic
Behavior meaning it frees up the
Consciousness so the Consciousness
doesn't have to be dealing with all the
tasks well when you free up the
Consciousness then you have time for
creative thinking
but here's the issue and this is the
catch
when the Consciousness is not focusing
on some job or some task and let's say
it's on a daydream mode it's thinking
about your vacation next week you're
going on vacation and you're thinking
about the plans of your vacation in your
conscious mind
well if your conscious mind is thinking
about the vacation who's running the
day-to-day moment-to-moment life the
answer is the subconscious but now
here's the catch
does the conscious mind observe the
behavior as it automatically plays from
the subconscious mind and I go back and
say well where was your mind I was
thinking about the future well if it's
thinking about the future then it wasn't
paying attention right and the answer is
aha
the nature of the trade-off is the
subconscious mind can run everything
when the conscious mind is busy
if the conscious mind is busy that's not
paying attention and so when it's not
paying attention it does not see the
programs that are playing the
subconscious mind
so to give you like an amusing antidote
about it is you know somebody and you
know their parent and you realize that
this person and a parent pretty much
have the same behavior and so you in
enthusiasm you burst on the scene you
say you know Mary you're just like your
mom
as soon as you say that to Mary back
away from Mary why because she's not
going to take this in welcoming news for
her she's going to say like how can you
say that to her she's not like her mom
at all
and the issue is interesting he's like
the joke is everybody can everybody else
can see that Mary's like her mom but
Mary can't why not the answer is because
when she's playing the programs which
she got from her mother which are in her
subconscious she's playing them because
she's not paying attention and so when
they play she doesn't see them so she's
surprised when people say that she
behaves like her mom even though that's
what her life is all about
now the conclusion of why all this
dialogue and why was it all important
the answer is this
that we do not see the subconscious when
it plays the subconscious has programs
in it that we primarily get from other
people in our development and the
significance about that is that if we
are operating from the subconscious mind
or not seeing it then we're also not
seeing that we're playing programs that
may not be in any way supporting who we
are and what we want the programs those
are in the conscious mind
so the idea is when life doesn't work
when you don't find that relationship
that your positive thinking was looking
for when you don't get that Health that
you were looking for because your
positive thinking was asking for it we
have a tendency therefore to blame the
outside world because as far as I know
my intention was for all these wonderful
things and when I don't get it it can't
be me because I have all these wonderful
positive intentions
what we didn't see was while we were
having those positive intentions using
our conscious mind for those positive
intentions the subconscious was running
the show
and we didn't see that we generally
sabotage
and destroy or limit our own lives with
behaviors that are not supporting us
and why this is important is because
then we all generally cop the attitude
that there are forces outside of me that
control my life and I am a victim of
this world and I can't do anything about
it as a victim
and as soon as you buy that
you are a victim
and the only problem was it was your own
subconscious programming that that led
to the life that you have and that if
you can understand that and then try to
work with it then you can change your
subconscious programming and change your
life we have a wonderful protection
system called the adrenal system and
when we're really stressed the adrenal
hormones go through our system shut down
our immune system shut down our growth
and maintenance of the body while we
allocate all the energy to run away well
this is not a problem if the fear is
something like a saber-toothed tiger
that shows up we can run away and escape
and then go back to growth again I'm not
saying in terms of fears there's throw
caution to the wind yes there are
legitimate fears out there but the
extent of the fears that we've been
programmed with are so overblown at this
point that we are weakening ourselves
and through the stress hormones that are
released in our body we are becoming a
capacitated so therefore it's not to let
go of fear fear is very important it's
required for our survival but to
recognize a cycle of 24 7 365 is
detrimental to our health and our
Vitality now is the time for us to take
care of ourselves take care of our
community and take care of nature as
well and when we go inside we must
remember to reprogram our limiting fears
about the world and ourselves and
recognize how truly powerful we are but
to do that we must stop the stress
hormones from controlling our life it's
time for us to take our power back and
not live in fear because that is what
weakens us and it is love that empowers
us the new science that is just coming
into the Forefront of our world today is
is something called epigenetic control
what I was teaching was genetic control
controlled by genes the new science
which is now coming around is called
epigenetic control and what that means
in the you understand the prefix Epi
means above so you say epidermis that
means the layer above the dermis skin if
I say epigenetic control literally it
says control above the genes and this is
the new science and why is it profound
because when you teach genetic control
you teach victimization you didn't pick
the genes as far as we know the genes
control your traits you can't change the
genes so you become victimized by your
heredity and the new science epigenetic
control reveals how your response to the
environment as you change your response
to the environment you change the fate
of yourselves just like in the petri
dish that makes you a master because
you're the one that has the opportunity
to change your perception and response
so therefore you're the one that
controls your genes be because you made
it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
about the law of attraction Secrets
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there you'd have to
become aware of your unconscious habits
and behaviors and even what you say and
modify them and then you'd have to look
at those emotions that keep you anchored
to the past and decide if those emotions
belong in your future